we would go right into cuddling like
spooning on a bed I'm going to change
the world one snuggle at a time Madison
Wisconsin snuggle house was gearing up
to offer professional snuggling services
for stressed-out clients when the
business ran into hassles from the
police regulators and the City
Attorney's Office it's just hard to
believe that this is a legitimate pure
snuggling business the assistant city
attorney says she doesn't know any man
who wants to just snuggle and the police
threatened to bust the business with
undercover sting operations yeah I'm
here to be snuggled with Jerry I think
it is law enforcement figured the stings
would unmask the snuggle house as a
hooker house are you Jerry
yeah I'm Jerry the police boast about
making frequent use of undercover stings
to bust people for everything from drugs
to alcohol and sex related offenses
sometimes they hang out at local
restaurants trying to bait people into
stealing iPhones Thank You Jerry a
cuddle crackdown in the city where naked
bike rides are an annual affair
I brought my monkey and where plenty of
businesses offer massages bikini waxes
and all kinds of things where clients
are far less clothed than during a
snuggle session can I touch a monkey of
course you can touch my monkey but still
ultimately the snuggle house buckled
under the pressure and closed before it
opened so snuggly now are you but come
on don't cops have better things to do
the States Attorney General says human
trafficking is on the rise in Wisconsin
and is especially common in cities the
crime often involves forced sex where
victims are children as well as adults
so I don't know maybe Madison law
enforcement could spend more time
busting sex trafficking reigns and
relaxed about what consenting nonviolent
adults are doing snuggle Joe followed
the show on Twitter submit your nominees
for next month and check out peaceful
streets this month be cured follower the
big shot with Twitter in me are you
twittering me
you